alors merci je voudrais dire merci à
aurore d'être avec nous or vous avez 18
ans aujourd'hui
vous étiez une jeune femme mineure au
moment des faits vous aller témoigner
sur les méthodes utilisées dont
christian quesada pour obtenir des
photos dénudées de vous lasser encore à
un autre délire parce que on avait vu
que lui envoyer des photos voilà de son
sexe on avait emeline qui étaient avec
nous avant-hier et vous vous venez de
suivre vous êtes étudiante
donc il vous a envoyé déjà une photo de
son sexe alors que vous étiez mineurs
comment ça s'est passé exactement qu'ils
ont commis il entre en contact avec vous
en fait j'avais bien un tweet par
rapport à lui parce que j'étais un peu
déçu qu'ils soient éliminés des hausses
comédiens comme toussaint voilà on était
vrai et finalement il a fini par
s'abonner à moi et il est venu me parler
en privé un message privé
bah vous étiez plutôt fan de lui parce
que voilà vous le suivez tous les jours
enfin régulièrement mais c'est ça oui
alors à quel moment ils vous envoyer des
photos à vous aussi de te de son sexe
comment ça s'est passé c'est que dès le
départ pas la même histoire du verglas
appareils ton corps c'est ça c'était
même procédé donc il vous a dit qu'il
avait glissé sur une plaque de verglas
qui s'était ouvert le front est tordu le
zizi et il vous a ensuite envoyé des
photos alors c'est vrai que je vois il
ya plein de gens voilà qui qui disent
c'est complètement fou à chaque fois
cette histoire on dirait que c'est une
blague mais c'est pas du tout une blague
c'est incroyable aussi improbable que
cela puisse paraître c'est vraiment
comme ça que ça se passe où vous allez
est-ce que aurore est ce que vous avez
eu d'autres messages de jeune fille qui
ont maintenant que vous l'avez dit que
qui ont vécu la même chose que vous et
qui vous ont contacté pour dire ben moi
aussi j'ai vécu ça oui il ya plusieurs
personnes qui sont venues me direz qu'il
m'envoyait aussi les discussions et
c'est exactement la même chose toujours
l'espoir d'une autre jeune fille qui ont
les motifs qui vous disent que c'était
même scénario qui ont vécu la mer agit
comme en colère sur la photo plus bas
mais j'étais un peu choqué sur le coup
et enfin sur le coup j'ai supprimé la
photo parce que j'avais pas envie de
revoir ça plusieurs fois vous allez
parler vous à vos parents
il n'y a pas très longtemps sacrément
mais au début non c'est dans ces
personnes ces personnes leur parle tout
de suite pourquoi vous êtes-vous dit
j'en parlais tout de suite c'est chaud
c'est choquant oui oui et vous en avez
parlé à personne même pas une à des amis
proches mais il vous on a très peu de
personnes elles m'ont dit que c'était
facile et choquants qu' avec talent et
d'en parler des travaux par ondes ou non
et vous l'avez répondu que qu'est ce que
vous lui avez répondu à christian bale
alpha s'est pas avoué sur le coup je lui
ai dit que films et envoie une photo son
foin je lui ai dit la deuxième photo
elle n'était pas nécessaire voila voila
il faudrait pas là il a dit à désolé je
pensais que tu voulais voir les deux
après vous a demandé des photos à vous
lasser
c'est un autre procédé qu'eric emeline
et vous a demandé des photos de vous
dénuder comment il a procédé fait s'il
voulait qu'on fasse c'est une sorte
d'action vérité ou par téléphone
oui ça sur par message par mais sa joie
si vous êtes j'en voyais des photos de
mes pieds de mon nombril mais moi je
vais j'ai refusé mais c'était comme ça
qui fait et donc et il vous disait quoi
ensuite il a essayé de vous recontacter
trailer je pense il a joué sur le fait
qu'il n'avait pas vraiment confiance en
moi d'accord il a beaucoup appuyé sur ça
pourquoi ils vous lui disiez oui j'ai
pas confiance en moi et vous disais gens
s'ils voyaient avec mes tweets qui était
à qui monte règles souvent j'avais pas
confiance en moi
d'accord et il essayait de nous amadouer
en nous disant voilà je vais te redonner
confiance en toi qui dois avoir
confiance en toi tu dois peut-être mais
qu'est-ce qui vous disaient sur les
messages
il m'a dit qu'il l'avait fait avec une
autre fille avec ti salle avait donné
confiance en elle et nadia elle a peut
être un pareil avec toi vraiment prêt
vous voulez pas fait bien sûr les gens
que les aides les adolescentes on sait
sont souvent un peu complexés par leur
corps et c'est sous leur corps en pleine
transformation
merci c'est des pervers s'en servent
souvent pour dire mais si je te trouve
très jolie n'écoute pas les autres
montrant les photos du maire est très
belle et ses terrains c'est vraiment une
c'est vraiment permet à date heure et
pour autant vous l'avez pas signalez
vous l'avez pas bloqué vous avez
continué à entretenir une relation avait
un sentiment de honte pour vous raconter
qui vous comment pourquoi est ce qu'on
dit rien parce qu'on se sent salie prend
la tête peur qu'on ne crois pas à ça
aussi
puis j'étais gêné ce salon est
aujourd'hui hors proulx vous avez choisi
de témoigner aujourd'hui
parce que je me suis dit que c'était
bien ça ça presse était enfin de la
prévention ou les autres les autres
fruits
ces soirées que ça se reproduise oui il
faut pas oublier que quand on est
victime de ce genre de choses on n'ose
pas parler parce qu'on a peur qu'on le
fasse la réfection genre oui mais tu
l'avais seulement provoqué chercher
c'est toi qui l'a chauffé un peu c'est
pour ça qu'ils étaient en vie des photos
c'est pour ça qu'à peine victimes qui
n'osent pas aller porter plainte au
commissariat pour par peur de voir cette
réflexion d'un figure donc être les gens
sont déjà se renferme sur eux mêmes il
vous a menacé non pas imaginer deux fois
quand il envoie la photo il a dit on
parle à personne de gardes pour toi et
c'est la première phrase vous receviez
un truc salaces d'un homme
oui parce que